what types of companies are you trying
to buy so you're trying to buy is it a
certain price point is it a certain
business model is it a certain type of
owner what are you trying to buy yeah so
we first want to buy something that we
thinks gonna be durable and around for a
really long time so you know if you look
at our clone portfolio we are in the
swimming pool business like digging
holes in the ground shootin concrete
we're also manufacturing in that space
as well another company that's unrelated
in the backyard product space it's a
bunch of confused and sell through mass
retail we are with military recruitment
firm that was the first firm that I
acquired me t cross we've got a military
recruitment firm so it's not like Legion
for military yeah so we actually work I
mean we have number of different clients
but one of our main clients is a
civilian branch of the Navy that
resupplies the ships that never came
into port so it's called Military
Sealift Command and we're responsible
for finding and onboarding all of their
staff on a yearly basis so it's like a
staffing firm for a ship yeah well for a
whole branch of military so it's there's
their staffing and there's a lot
fourteen fifteen seventeen hundred
civilian Mariners a year into that
division so it's a it's a pretty large
operation digital digital yeah yeah we
have you know online application
products but not mostly I think there's
a lot of physical activities as well we
have a it's not sexy where the rubber
meets the road real-deal business so we
were talking about some of the
differences you guys owned so me across
which is a military recruitment firm
swimming pool business back here at the
base so you have a couple of there so
you were saying you're looking for
durable businesses that's likely
attribute one what are the other sort of
key attributes you're looking at
yeah I mean so we want to find a
leadership team that we can partner with
there's so many you know it's so hard to
grow a business right and so a lot of
the businesses were looking at we either
called has been right before the line of
professionalization or maybe has just
crossed
and there's this this real interesting
you know sort of in-between gap where a
lot of these firms they're they're too
big to be small and too small to be big
and the leadership teams kind of capped
out they're just brute forcing as much
as they possibly can but they don't have
the the system's the talent on staff to
be able to grow larger and so a lot of
the times we're trying to figure out
from them you know do they want to get
bigger there's some there's some firms
we talked to and and they say well even
though so yeah I want to get bigger but
the you know the CEO is answering 60
calls a day on a cell phone and I mean
there's just no way right and so we're
looking for a leadership team that I
think has the base skills is really
really excellent at what they do and
we're looking for the company to have a
position in the marketplace that is
protected somehow right so I mean we're
not looking to get into just commodity
type businesses we want them to have
something unusual about them that we can
really build on and help them grow and
then you know this doesn't sound like a
like a maybe a no-brainer obvious one
but we gotta get to a price in terms
that that that are acceptable to both
parties right and there's roughly 400
decisions that have to be made sort of
dream that acquisition process I mean
that's 400 opportunities to not agree
and and it's very difficult and
time-consuming and so a lot of us just
trying to make sure that we think that a
deal could be done as well
[Music]